c'est la hausse la plus rapide
enregistrée depuis le mois de mai 2020
en afrique le nombre de nouvelles
contaminations aux colis de 19 a
augmenté de 83% cette semaine par
rapport à la semaine précédente selon
les données de l'om est ce pour autant
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
recense moins de décès que lors des
précédentes vagues le nombre de nouveaux
cas double tous les 5 jours rythme le
plus rapide enregistrée depuis le début
de l'année le nombre de décès a même
diminué de 19% par rapport à la semaine
précédente une hausse des contaminations
alors que le variant omicron a été
détecté dans plusieurs pays du continent
africain le 15 décembre le kenya par
exemple a annoncé avoir détecté les
trois premiers cas de ce variant sur son
territoire même scénario au rwanda qui
lui a fait part de six premiers cas le
pays a d'ores et déjà annoncé de
nouvelles restrictions c'est donc dans
ce contexte que l' oms a tenu à rappeler
aux pays riches de ne pas accaparer
toutes les doses de vaccin au détriment
des pays les plus pauvres il y à un
risque que les stocks mondiaux soit une
nouvelle fois redirigée vers les pays à
hauts revenus qui veulent accumuler les
vaccins pour protéger leur population
jusqu'à l'excès la seule façon de
ralentir cette maladie est de faire en
sorte que toutes les personnes à risque
soient vaccinés nous sommes en train
d'oublier cela dans certains pays malgré
ces alertes la demande de l'inde et de
l'afrique du sud de lever les brevets
sur les vaccins est toujours au point
mort pour cela un vote à l'unanimité est
nécessaire au niveau de l'organisation
mondiale du commerce mais une poignée de
pays riches sont toujours réticents à la
levée des brevets comme l'allemagne par
exemple en juin dernier chez le
parlement européen s'était pourtant
prononcé en faveur d'une levée
temporaire des brevets mais depuis rien
n'a bougé notez que selon les dernières
estimations de l'om est ce au rythme
actuel l'afrique devra attendre 2024
pour atteindre les 70 % de personnes
vaccinées un seuil considéré comme
essentiel pour maîtriser la pandémie